بالفعل معز بعد الاختبار العسير نعيش
كرنفال حقيقي هنا في محيط ملعب المدينه
التعليميه صراحه كلها هؤلاء يقولون اننا
الان دخلنا لمنطقه مجهوله ولكن هذه
المنطقه جميله ورائعه
اوساط الجماهير المغربيه
[تصفيق]
ارسال رساله الى المنتخب الوطني المغربي
والى ايضا الى الجماهير المغربي في في
المغرب
ماذا بعد هذا الاداء البطوله هذا الاداء
كل اسعد كل المغاربه وكل العرب وهنا نفتخر
بهذا الانتصار وهو رد اعتبار
للمونديال ديال 2018 اللي خرجنا معه مع
اسبانيا ومع البرتغال
الان الحمد لله بوجودك داخل الملعب همم
ان شاء الله في المستقبل القريب ان شاء
الله هل لدينا فعلا امان للمرور
فلم يصدقوني قلت لهم بلجيكا والكرواتيا
الى اسبانيا اوروبا فقسيناه هنا في قطر
2022 كم كنتم كبار ياسود الاطلس انتم
الكبار انتم كبارا بمثل بمعنى ما تحكي
بمعنى ما تقول الكلمه انه المغرب يا ساده
شكرا هذه كما تشاهدون معز همم اجواء فرح
عالم هنا في في استاد البيت صافا يتجرد
الاعلامي وان يبتعد عن هذه الفرحه لكن كما
تشاهدون جماهيرنا فرحه وما اعتقد ان هذه
الفرحه ستستمر السعاده المقبله